hey guys it's Justine and today what is
inside this box is something that is so
perfect that I think that it was
actually made just for me like it should
have my name on it but it doesn't the
what name or rather a logo that it has
on it is the razer logo because this is
a brand new 13 inch blade stealth and it
is pink I think that you can feel my
excitement like I'm trying to keep sort
of calm because sometimes when I get
really excited you guys say that I'm
overreacting but I'm not I just get very
excited about things that I like and
then I'm passionate about so with that
being said let's open it up also for
this unboxing since everything is
beautiful in pink we've got this this is
one of my favorite unboxing knives and
not only are we going to be unboxing the
laptop but I've also got a bunch of
their pink accessories as well so that
isn't a box over here just know that
this video is probably never gonna end
but first friends the laptop this is
also one of my favorites it is so
beautiful oh there's a box inside of a
box surprise you've also got this don't
leave that anymore
first things first we've got our power
cable
this is so freaking exciting look at
this so this is the 13-inch Wow what I
love about this is definitely something
that I can also travel with look how
beautiful this is
fish listen I think my nails maybe are a
little aggressive it's so light I'm so
shocked so we've got two USB ports here
we've got a USB a USB see we've also got
the same but also a headphone jack I
also have in here it's this is this a
note is it a note for me so they don't
actually call this pink they call it
quartz which is great because quartz
crystal is probably one of them that's
one of my favorite crystals look at this
holographic stickers you guys are about
to see the most aggressive quartz set up
ever
let's turn this on it's so beautiful
like this thing looks so great I'm
honestly shocked but it looks so good
so this is a part of the blade stealth
line and this particular model came out
in December but now it is out in pink
well it's actually called quartz if
that's the official razor color but if
you ask me and this looks pink to me I'm
gonna plug this in and you let it charge
up and now let's get to some other
really fun courts unboxings oh my gosh
I've unbox a few courts items previously
but a bunch of these are not necessarily
new product so they are new in the color
courts I have dropped something oh my
gosh I'm so oh shoot this makeup powder
to just drop this and then I drop the
knife on top of it this is why not a
beauty hero oh boy we've got so many
things to add Vox here not really sure
what to start with but let's just think
about this logically I've got my laptop
I'm probably gonna want a mouse and then
for my mouse I'm gonna need a mousepad
so let's start with those things so
beautiful so I have a bunch of other
pink razor things that I got previously
but my sister and I split them up
because she took half and then I took
the other half so this is great because
now we both can have pink things so now
we've got our mouse make sure I don't
lose added pieces you can swap out this
little guy if you want a shorter a
little button so we've got our mouse
we've got our laptop we're gonna need a
mousepad
obviously this thing is huge I have been
eyeing one of these up for quite a while
actually
and today is my day for stickers
watch these are so beautiful so what's
great about this is it has LED lights
all around it I'm also working on
redoing my office again so this is gonna
be such a perfect addition yes okay this
is so incredible you basically can just
have an entire freaking desk be a
mousepad this is gonna be great for the
setup that I'm currently working on it's
probably gonna be a while until I finish
it because realistically I've been
trying to do this for over a year and
Here I am not accomplishing all of the
tasks that I would like probably a
little aggressive for my laptop setup
here but Never Say Never
it says Justin Bieber this is gonna get
interesting because they only have two
USB ports on here but what I do have is
on this base station for my headphones
this gives me three additional ports so
what that means my friends that's gonna
be the next thing that I have to open so
it's great as you can also adjust all of
these colors inside of the Razer synapse
app which you would think that I would
have internet in my house but for
whatever reason spectrum it keeps
failing me so I can't even connect to
the internet right now hi I'm Justine I
don't even have internet like I'm gonna
have to tether to my phone so we're
going to open this up next so that we'll
be able to have additional Hulu USB
ports this stand is actually really nice
this looks so good my new set up like
I'm so hyped to show it to you guys so
we've got our headphones stand now we're
gonna plug this in over here I'm gonna
be so wild I know there's a lot of
cables going on but there are LED lights
here we've got LED lights at the bottom
of the headphone stand this is the siren
X this is one of the mini little
microphones that they have and I love
this one because I probably will use
this when I'm traveling I have one of
their larger ones it's actually the
microphone that I use all the time to
record all of my vo I'm running out of
room I love that everything matches I
feel like the stereotypical girl right
now but you know what I'm living a
that I never thought would be possible
when I was a little girl like I wanted
pink accessories guess we didn't have so
also inside his box who we've got a USB
cable base stand here for this looks
like this just Roos in here I'm not
suppose here this is like freakin
Barbie's Dreamhouse Barbies gaming Dream
House Wow
I'm loving it so this is one of the new
Kraken headphones also comes in courts
the ear cups have been updated they also
have a little extra padding at the top
so for more comfort and the new
microphone has better noise cancelling
it smells fresh it smells like a fresh
freakin headset this is so excessive I
can't even handle it so I can also plug
in my headphones into the microphone as
well
so we've only got one more thing left to
open and it's the keyboard
yeah this looks good I've run out of
desk space okay well here's the keyboard
Razer definitely has outdone themselves
with their courts okay we're here
setting up I just heard headphones on
when we watch a youtube video we hear a
song or something what's uh what's
popping on YouTube let's see I look up
Slayer Angel of Death this video that is
not even a video it has 18 million views
I just keep thinking of high school
Justine listening just layer and it was
a time of my life I don't regret it one
of the cool things in the Razer synapse
app like I was mentioning before if
you're actually able to customize all of
the led colors so inside chroma studio
you have all of these little presets and
effects that you can add you can change
colors all kinds of plugins and add-ons
that you can get to work with the LED
lights with razor with your hue lights
those really cool because you can not
only control the LED lights on your
computer but you basically control the
lights in your house as well let me just
show off one of these lights
I'll show off the big guy does that help
can you guys see some things let's click
over here to lighting yeah that looks
good the breathing ah it's so good it's
so good
I mean basically just making everything
pink go figure
pink okay oh my gosh everything is
everything is breathing okay I'll turn
the lights back on well thank you guys
for watching I hope you guys enjoyed
this unboxing I'm definitely looking
forward to more people getting their
hands on these because they are so
awesome and I'm a huge fan of Fraser and
all of their products and I'm especially
a huge fan of the quartz line I know it
might be stereotypical
but I don't care and neither should you
again this is the new quartz 13 inch
blade stealth laptop huge thank you to
razor for sending me these things to
check out this video isn't sponsored but
they did send me these things and I'm so
excited to set up my new gaming office
and my editing Bay's I have so much
stuff in store for 2019 and I just I
need to get started on it it's so crazy
because January is pretty much already
over we're already hopping into February
but thank you guys for watching and
thanks for coming along for this
unboxing now I got to go out at this
video and put my knives away so with
that I'll see you guys in my next video
[Music]